salut vous avez compris en lisant le
titre de la vidéo qui m'était arrivé
quelque chose d'un petit peu particulier
mais qui risque d'arriver à la plupart
des mecs en plus alors que tu sois un
homme ou une fille je te conseille de
regarder cette vidéo jusqu'au bout je
précise ça parce que j'ai regardé les
statistiques de mon audience est moins
d'audience est composé à 78 % d'hommes
deux garçons et donc à 22 % de filles
parce que c'était important que ça fasse
bien 100% quand même au final
et puis vous l'avez compris mais donc
arrivés très récemment quelque chose de
très spécial de très étrange mais avant
d'y venir il faut que je vous précise
quelque chose d'autre si on regarde les
480 vidéo que j'ai fait la première
vidéo se passe avec un mec la deuxième
avec une fille j'essaye de respecter une
parité comme sa fille garçon à la base
y'a même pas une volonté particulière
c'est en fait c'est juste logique c'est
le quotidien quoi est ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est vraiment très particulier
c'est quelque chose donc que j'ai envie
de dire mais je me dis surtout que si
une fille tenait le discours que je vais
tenir
elle s'en prendraient plein la gueule
j'ai fait à peu près donc autant de
featurings avec des filles qu'avec des
garçons et à chaque fois dans les
commentaires il ya quelque chose d'assez
merveilleux alors forcément il ya
toujours des commentaires négatifs et
des commentaires positifs ça c'est
normal mais dans les commentaires
négatifs
je me suis aperçu de quelque chose
d'assez fabuleux quand jamais que
quelqu'un n'aime pas sur ma chaîne les
commentaires ont tendance à dénigrer le
contenu qui produit sur sa propre chaîne
alors ça peut être violent industeel way
avec sa chaîne de merde tonnerre j'aime
pas son contenu
c'est pourri ce qui fait par contre à
chaque fois que j'ai une fille sur la
chaîne dans les commentaires ce que je
veux dire c'est des critiques sur sur
son physique sur le fait qu'elle soit
une fille sur comment elles s'expriment
où elle s'exprime pas si elle a l'air
intelligent tout pas sur les vêtements
qu'elle porte sur le fait qu'on ait
couché ensemble pas sur le fait qu'elle
ait couché avec d'autres youtuber ou pas
etc etc
c'est fabuleux ça d'un côté on juge le
contenu d'une personne et de l'autre
côté on juge en fait le fait que ce soit
une fille alors j'ai décidé
qu'aujourd'hui c'est moi qui avais mes
règles
voilà comme ça c'est pour ça que je
m'énerve mais je vous rassure c'est de
l'énervement maîtriser un d'ailleurs que
vous soyez une fille ou un garçon et que
vous vous sentiez du bon côté de la
force ou du mauvais côté dans ce que je
raconte vraiment regarder la vidéo en
entier elle va pas être très longue
bon je suis pas féministe d'ailleurs je
sais même pas si un homme peut être
féministe ou pas ou texte est ministre
ou pas j'ai fait aucune recherche là
dessus donc je ne sais pas par contre ce
que je sais c'est que je suis
pragmatique ce que je viens de vous dire
sur le commentaire c'est complètement
pragmatique quand
le fait qu'on puisse apercevoir les
commentaires qu'il ya des insultes qui
sont unisexes par exemple comme youtube
les yeux sur ma chaîne et se fait
insulter de miss je me dis tiens
pourquoi jamais de mecs reçoivent une
insulte le petit peu symétrique
ben parce que ça existe pas en fait une
milf il ya un vieux beau c'est la suite
la plus approchant un vieux beau et
alors ça m'amène à comprendre quelque
chose des filles qui refuse maintenant
de faire des featuring sur les chaînes
d'autres mecs parce qu'elle faisait en
ont marre en fait de sueur insulter
parce qu'il faut quand même prendre
conscience de quelque chose quand on
fait une vidéo avec quelqu'un sur la
chaîne de quelqu'un d'autre
évidemment qu'on va dire les
commentaires après on lit on regarde un
petit peu commencé accueilli ce qu'on a
fait qu'est ce que vous en pensez
évidemment et quand je vois ce que je
lis moi ring sur mes propres vidéos
alors que je crois que j'ai plutôt de
basile communauté bienveillante
je me dis que ouais je comprends
pourquoi elle refuse maintenant de faire
des films et je comprend aussi pourquoi
il ya des filles qui veulent plus lancé
sur youtube ou qu'ils arrêtent leurs
chaînes ou qu'il ya un bon projet de
chaîne et qu'ils le font pas alors
forcément les filles elles se
soutiennent entre elles mais c'est pas
normal
on devrait avoir une communauté mixte un
petit peu partout en fait et aussi
bienveillante
bon et puis si on fait une analyse
rapide des commentaires on va pas se
mentir c'est toujours des commentaires
issus de la frustration sexuelle soit de
gens qui arrivent pas à choper soit de
gens qui sont frustrés soit de gens et
qui la fille rappelle quelqu'un avec qui
ils ont eu des soucis émotionnel soit de
gens libres et ils soient de gens qui
ont des problèmes de libido et en fait
ça m'amène à dire quelque chose et tu
vas voir la réflexion elle est
intéressante c'est à dire que les mecs
disent toujours quand une fille un
problème à la ces règles bien elle
devrait un petit peu se contenir à se
retenir et ce qu'elle met un petit peu
ça va quoi mais nous les mecs on n'a pas
un changement hormonal en permanence en
fait avec la libido exacerbée qu'on
retrouve dans les commentaires qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs aussi dans la vie
courante malheureusement peut-être
qu'elle géreront mieux leurs émotions le
jour où on va mieux gérer les notes de
ce côté là tu vois la mise en
perspective des problèmes hormonaux
parce que vraiment quand je lis les
commentaires sur les chaînes des filles
c'est ouf mois puis sur internet que ce
soit sur youtube sur des forums etc
on le sait très bien l'anonymat aide est
favori ça malheureusement et puis l'âge
des personnes et et je vais juste finir
là-dessus que vous soyez un mec qui
pensent comme moi quelqu'un qui fait
partie de la fameuse majorité
silencieuse ou une fille
faut absolument vous impliquer mais pour
ça c'est hyper simple n'entre et surtout
pas en conflit avec ceux qui écrivent
ces commentaires c'est parce que je vous
demande vous allez perdre votre temps
dans la plupart du temps par contre vous
pouvez signaler les commentaires
offensants et encore plus important
noeud qu laisser l'espace commentaires
aux mains et aux prises de ces gens là
pierre sur une vidéo qui fait 100 mille
vue imaginons qu'il ya 200 commentaires
se lève 200 commentaires il y en a 100
hyper violent et négatifs comme ça je
parle bien de méchanceté gratuite pas de
critique constructive
la fille qui lit les commentaires qui
lui sont adressés ava lire la moitié des
messages un sur deux là dessus alors que
nous on sait que c'est pas représentatif
puisqu'il y 100000 vue et c'est sans
commentaire sur 100000 vue c'est que
dalle mais quand tu lis les commentaires
c'est la moitié de ce que tu lis donc
vous pouvez agir en étant vous même pas
silencieuse c'est à dire si vous avez
aimé la personne la vidéo ce qu'elle
fait vous pouvez mettre un commentaire
là dessus
vous savez c'est comme les votes
extrêmes les blaireaux il n'oublie
jamais de donner leurs voix
eh bien là c'est pareil les gros lourds
n'oublie jamais de mettre un commentaire
donc on peut tous se responsabiliser moi
le premier en mettant des commentaires
sur les vidéos qu'on trouve cool quand
on voit une fille qui se fait allumer
dans les com et qu'on n'est pas d'accord
et b ça vaut le coup de mettre un
commentaire positif pour contrecarrer ça
parce qu'il faut qu'on reprenne les
espaces commentaires aussi un petit peu
en main voilà je pense que cette vidéo
était un petit peu fouillis mais je
pense aussi que vous avez compris le
message que je voulais donner et ce
n'était pas vraiment un coup de plus
c'est un constat et un peut-être un
petit réveil de deux trois personnes au
moins se seraient déjà génial et
maintenant je pense que vous avez
compris pourquoi j'ai mis ce titre si
une fille avait eu le malheur de faire
exactement la vidéo que je viens de
faire dans les commentaires on lui
aurait à guy assez bon à la ces règles
[Musique]
oh